our next speaker is
heat and shot and if you know anything
about this guy you've probably seen his
face everywhere i don't know how he
sleeps or
if he does sleep but he's pretty much
everywhere he's a mentor at 500 startups
he's an active blogger and is the
founder of crazy egg and kissmetrics
along with neil patel
kissmetrics has raised about 13 million
dollars in funding
funding and heaton leads a team of 50 50
members he's going to talk about how
he's been able to be so productive
so let's give a warm welcome to heaton
shaw
i'm just going to get started because i
have a shitload of slides and i got to
get through all of them so i'm going to
talk really fast you might not
understand what i'm saying
just kidding so uh when we when uh sam
uh asked me to speak uh we actually did
a little experiment we did a blog post
and uh he asked all of you and a bunch
of other people to
ask me what i should speak on and what
happened was a lot of people had a lot
of different things
to ask me about that were very specific
very tactical
and what ended up happening is that i
decided to talk about whatever i wanted
to
but it was actually based on a question
from sam and the question was
why are you more productive than most
people and this is like at the end of
his email after like these five or six
other
sort of topics and what i really
realized is that most people that are on
stage today are going to tell you
tactics about how they did something or
how you can do something etc
and i'm actually going to talk about
something completely different one i
don't know why people think i'm
productive i'm actually the laziest per
entrepreneur you'll ever meet i walk
around my office saying that
i don't do any work and hopefully this
talk will help you understand why i do
that uh or not
so i've had a computer since 1989. does
anyone recognize this
circuit board looking thing some of you
okay great so this is going to date me
so all of you are old too um and so
basically
uh this is a sound card that used to go
in computers when they were big metal
heavy boxes
um and i've been playing with them since
i was eight years old
the last language i learned though was q
basic
so i don't know if any of you are
familiar with that any of you familiar
with qbasic
cool awesome i don't know how to write
code
but with qbasic i used to terrorize
radio shack employees
so i would go create a little loop and
like run it and then they wouldn't know
what to do because they didn't know how
to use control c
and get out of it and it was all ms-dos
at the time
so uh yeah that that's about as far as i
get when it comes to uh programming
that being said like i said can't design
can't write code
but um i work with awesome developers
and designers
and uh some of the things i'm going to
talk about are how how i was able to do
that
uh but also i make them feel like this
sometimes they're all super heroes but
like when i talk sometimes
they get kind of frustrated and give me
that look i've seen that look a lot
and the reason is i can always out
google them so that's my superpower if
anyone needs to know i can out google
you
bring it they can tell me like two or
three things about some variable or
parameter or whatever and usually i can
google it for them
so to prepare this talk i really wanted
to think about hustle
and think about what the word meant
because i think there's a it's an
interesting word
and uh i got links at the bottom my
slides are on slideshare
i'll tweet them out right after this i
forgot to before this because of sam
but anyways uh if you go look on urban
dictionary there's a bunch of stuff in
the middle of these two
things that says things about selling
drugs and other things like that
but this is basically what hustle means
it's uh basically anything you need to
make money
if you're making money you hustling
that's apparently what this is about
and this is like a way different talk
than anything i've ever done before i'm
going to share all kinds of stuff that i
haven't shared before
and i'm going to get right into it so
i've been doing business on the web for
11 years
i don't know how to code so apparently
i'm a hustler i do know how to make
money
i'd say lots of it but i'm not yeah lots
of it
and the one thing i know from
kissmetrics
these are actually our kissmetrics
values and we only have five of them we
like to keep it simple kissmetrics the
kiss part stands for keep it simple
stupid
um somebody actually walked up to me and
i know we're at a non-tech conference
because someone walked up to me earlier
today i know you're in the room right
now
and they said they really like my logo
and this logo that i'm wearing which is
the kissmetrics logo and usually uh when
that happens they usually know what the
logo is
but i was stumped because he didn't know
what the logo was he didn't even know
what kissmetrics was so
that's awesome i actually feel really
good about that because there's a lot
more people that need to know about the
businesses
that i run
and i've been theming my talks based on
value at kissmetrics so i'm going to
talk about the value that
we used for this that i'm using for this
talk so the value is
take care of people and the reason
i want to talk about that today and a
lot of the talks gonna be around those
kind of things
is because when you when you think of
the word hustle you think of money
you don't actually think about people
and uh the biggest person that matters
in anyone's lives whether you want to
believe it or not
is probably yourself and uh the the way
that i'm so productive is i basically
invest in myself so now you're gonna
hear a whole bunch of tactics a whole
bunch of things
about sort of how i invest myself and
how all of you can too
again a lot different a lot more of a
different talk think of it as like
self-help for hustlers
if you want to put it that way and
there's three parts to it
learning communication and context and
you'll learn about all these three and
hopefully have tactics that you can take
home with you
so that you can sort of try to be like
me if anyone ever wanted to
learning so uh
also one thing i'll mention is a lot of
these tactics a lot of these things are
things that a lot of friends of mine
have heard me talk about but there are
also things that i don't see anybody
talking about it's not something
i have read in a blog post about uh in
terms of holistically how to do this
stuff
so for for me learning i think that's
the only thing that matters personally
uh and especially when you can't write
code because you can't actually write
code make something launch it to
customers
but you can definitely learn as fast as
you can and i do really believe at this
time there's more information out there
than any
any any other sort of time in history
and so
learning is really what you should be
optimizing for there's actually a book
on the topic
this guy josh kaufman wrote a book it's
called the first 20 hours how to learn
anything
fast obviously you can guess why that
resonated with me considering this topic
so i did want to share the book
he actually talks about how you can
learn ruby in less than 20 hours as well
so in case any of you want to learn
programming which you should even though
i haven't yet
although i keep threatening that i will
i just turned 33 yesterday and i'm
threatening that
by 40 i'll learn how to program
uh and and i threaten this to my
engineers because i'm sure it's
something that they they're really
looking forward to
all my questions one tactic uh tim
ferriss wrote this blog post about
how to read 300 faster in 20 minutes
it's really useful
if you're into reading you can take this
tactic
i personally actually don't use the
tactics in here in this blog post uh the
reason is i don't actually
uh read text but i'll talk about that in
a second
another thing is a site called get
abstract it's basically
summarizes books for you and it's really
amazing
very thorough summaries you have to pay
for it though
and there's also an audio component to
it youtube
anybody know about this trick you can
actually listen to youtube videos
at 2x speed people sound like chipmunks
it's pretty awesome but and here's the
trick you have to
get through like the first 20 30 seconds
and then
you actually start understanding what
people are saying
audible this is actually my my favorite
trick and and this is the exact reason
so i listen to audible at 3x speed there
isn't a single book i've read in the
last
i don't know 18 months that i haven't
read at 3 xp
actually listened to at 3x speed again
people sound like chipmunks for the
first 30 seconds after that i believe
and i don't know any science around this
i haven't really researched it i just
really enjoy
listening to people like chipmunks or
speak like chipmunks but
basically i believe you start
understanding what they're saying now
there's
one book that i i haven't read yet
because i couldn't really
do it uh it's basically a book called
the goal
i think uh it's one of jeff bezos's
favorite book uh books and it's narrated
by a french gentleman
and i had a very hard time doing 3x and
i actually had to go all the way down to
1.52x so
you know every rule is meant to be
broken every everything i say is
so you know
whatever this is my favorite thing that
i've read in the last 18 months
months i've read it about three or four
times and i say red but i heard it at 3x
speed
it's a book called the five elements of
effective thinking
and the reason i really like this is it
helps me think
and i think learning is all about sort
of getting inputs so you can think
and for me i want to get that those
inputs as fast as i can
also it helps me understand fast talkers
better too
so uh on to communication
and really i i was working on these
slides and i was actually i had a buddy
with me i was working on him on a big
70-inch screen because
i don't know it's kind of fun that way
and we were looking at this slide and
he's like
well can you and i'm like well what do
you mean can i of course i can talk
about this he's like no no
can you i said oh can you communicate
got it yeah i think most of us think we
can but we always can get better at it
right
so one of the big things i learned is
it's very important to communicate and
it's very important to figure out how
you can do it and when you're
communicating you're obviously
communicating
with somebody else so uh one of the
things that i
really thought about was um
personalities
and i used to really be allergic how
many of you are into personality tests
or have ever
ever taken one even okay so everyone's
kind of taken one and all that how many
of you think are allergic to them
okay not enough all right that's great
uh i guess i'm special
uh but anyways i put this picture of
food because most people are allergic to
food and stuff uh my kids alert they're
allergic to a lot of things so i thought
it was pretty cool and also
the pie chart most of the uh personality
tests have some form of a pie chart and
those always freak me out
because then that's something else you
have to understand and understand how to
like
understand but i had kids
and my first kid was actually when i was
15 is my co-founder neil
he's actually my brother-in-law and he
was 11 at the time that's his
site and him on the left i'm sure some
of you have heard of him because he's
also apparently a hustler
and that's him taking care of my two
kids so technically
i had him who i had to communicate with
because he's my co-founder but i've
known him a very long time
married to his sister actually and then
i had kids who are both
quite different even though one of them
is a baby she still has she's already
starting to get a personality
and so after i kind of figured this out
i started researching because you know
that's what you do
on the web you start googling i guess
and i found this blog post on hbr
uh or hbs or whatever that site and uh
they talk about the top sources of work
conflict and
number one is personal insecurity so
someone just being insecure a new job
or just you know generally being
insecure about things uh the desire for
power and control this is why i don't
work at a big company uh i call that
politics
and then uh habitual victimhood but once
i started really dig into this i
realized that it's actually just
people's personalities and how other
people make them feel
and so on that note i'm going to talk
about
a scenario that i basically
discovered by understanding uh
personalities better
uh and and it's a very very just a
scenario that i had happen recently
so uh the summary based on our
personalities
is uh and i work with this person so
she's driven by winning
uh i'm more driven by having a deep
understanding
and this is basically how it manifests
so i'd ask her
what do you need from me it's a very
common question a lot of managers and
leaders or whatever will ask
i do it quite a bit especially if i
don't know what the answer is but that's
also a sign in itself for me
and she tells me she needs something and
then i ask her why
what i learned is it drives her nuts and
i really didn't i don't personally on a
personal level
intuitively understand why it drives her
nuts to be honest
but it drives her nuts and it has a lot
to do with her personality
and mine and she basically finds those
types of conversations derailment
and a waste of energy and i wouldn't
have really understood why or any of
that stuff unless i really understood
our personalities and the difference
between them
and the way i did that is uh there's
this uh system up here uh again
you'll see some pie charts soon don't
worry but it's called in color insights
and it the this is all about your sort
of behavioral orientations and it's a
way to kind of
uh in my opinion explain yourself to
yourself and it's got four things action
action people structure and ideas this
is actually my personal insight
inventory
uh there's basically three sections to
it behavior is basically um
the the the way you feel more most
confident and for me
there's a lot of yellow yellow is people
there's also a bunch of
blue blue as ideas and uh when you kind
of see the next slide you'll understand
kind of me a little bit better
so i'm just gonna get to that so i'm
gonna read these out because this this
is basically me
and it kind of blew my mind in a way
because it's pretty accurate
but i like to consult with informed
others
i explore ideas with valued colleagues
and develop extensive personal
knowledge hence this talk believe people
should be receptive to new ideas and
probe for information
and then i assess the value of any
activity or action based on the insight
and feelings
of self-worth it creates and its
positive impact on other people
so if i feel like i wasn't valuable in a
conversation or a meeting or something
it actually freaks me out right after
and then i start running it in my head
and try to figure out how i could do
better
it's just something natural i do i don't
even know why i do it and it
actually really bugs me and then i
sometimes will go ask the people hey was
that okay and they're like yeah it was
great we learned a lot blah blah blah
i'm like all right cool
so this positive impact on other people
is something that
uh sounds all hokey and weird but it's
part of my personality so
i don't know what to do with it another
quick trick in case none of that
mattered to you
about communication i wrote a blog post
about learning uh
writing better emails so just like all
of you i'm sure you know
actually i get angry and i don't
typically know what to do
so i basically now just draft an email
to the person
and and i send it i'm kidding
i draft the email and i save it i don't
include anything in the to field
and i and i sleep on it or whatever and
then i read it again and usually that
means i either don't send it
save it for later because i'm still
angry or
or write a much better email so that's
just a quick tactic for all of you
uh again in case you're still allergic
to personality tests and stuff
that is that one i showed before is my
favorite one though um
and uh this this this example is
basically just a
customer support example so at crazy ag
which launched in 2005 it's one of my
companies
uh i basically took care of support
customer support
for the first two years and myself
amongst all the other things i was doing
and that was back when i actually used
to do stuff
and uh this is what basically happened i
ended up being a line item
when people were trying to make a
decision between us and other
competitors
so just just another trick just help
people you know
share share what you know and uh really
care about customers but you've already
heard a lot of that already today so
uh this is the last section i have a
little bit of a
sort of long-winded thing at the end
it's not really long-winded it's just uh
something that
i like talking about and it's it's not
very much talked about so
i'm going to get into that in a second
but context is basically the idea of
you know a lot of times you'll hear
people say something
and then you'll have to correct them
because they don't actually understand
the context
so they might go tell you hey you should
go buy a luxury luxury car or something
but really you might not have the money
for it and this is a very crude example
but so you should buy like a like a
honda or a kia or something instead
but if someone tells you to buy a luxury
car they're not really understanding
your context if that's not affordable
for you
so that's just a simple way to explain
context in my mind
i also wrote about this a little bit
it's about how i give advice
one of the most common ways that people
uh like to ask questions is they'll ask
me about my own experience
so they might ask me about you know when
you started kissmetrics what did you do
about sales
how did you start your blog
you know when you raise money what you
know how'd you raise money
and uh i go i go into this deeper in the
blog post but
overall i try to reframe the question
because
every question that most entrepreneurs
and most people are asking
about me is excuse me really a question
about them
and that's something i've learned so i
just try to reframe it that way i can
get context because otherwise i'm just
telling my story
over and over and over again and
honestly that's boring for me
but it's also not value very valuable
for other people plus like i've spoken a
lot and i've written about stuff a lot
and
if you want to know my story go read it
online or watch a video instead let me
figure out how to help you
so this is why i really focus on this
sort of approach
uh as i was researching about questions
and contacts i ran into this book i like
books but i like listening to him as all
of you know
i'm about 90 done and i liked it it also
includes uh
talks about lean startup and eric reese
a little bit in it so it's kind of cool
and kind of
a newer book and it's called a more
beautiful question and it actually talks
about
questions how to ask them um and even
how to get a better understanding
because of questions
and stuff like that so
this is the last part it looks like i
only have a minute but i might stretch
it a little bit
um i hope that's okay although you guys
have a break and juice or something like
that so i'm sure i'm sure you're dying
to get there
and tired of me talking but uh the this
graphic the reason i put it up there is
uh a lot of times i'll get into
like philosophical sort of discussions
with entrepreneurs and stuff
and and many times it leads to
discussion about this right here this
is basically the idea that everyone's
against you um has anyone ever felt like
that
don't lie well i'll admit i have
so um uh you know and i don't like
feeling like that
and uh a lot of times it has to do for
me personally it has to do with like
competition or other companies and
things like that
and so i just wanted to get a better
understanding of founders entrepreneurs
or even
people hustling in general and sort of
the different
sort of mindsets so came up with a
little formula my buddy joe stump and i
did a podcast
on this um anyways that's a kind of
funny picture of him but he was looking
at the legos and these are these are the
two legos
it's basically uh pirates and explorers
that's the concept
uh explorers tend to be revolutionary so
these are the kind of people who
uh always always think uh that
whatever they're doing is innovative
revolutionary even if it maybe
isn't so that's why i use this cartoon
for that
and pirates are the ones that are
usually looking at something and trying
to
figure out how to get it even if someone
else has it so then
exact classic example is if a pirate
typically goes after explorers to go
steal their loot
uh and that's typically what i've seen
so this example is more like
something i commonly hear so what i
commonly hear is that
um i've i just heard this yesterday
uh some new product launched and
uh uh somebody who has a competing
product already in the market
was like oh yeah they've been trying to
use our product for like
three months now and i've been talking
to them uh thinking it's a sales pitch
for this other thing they're doing but
then they end up launching basically a
competitor to our business
so that's more of a pirate mentality and
you know right or wrong it doesn't
matter this is what people do
and so here's the difference and and my
my big question for all of you
if you don't leave with anything else or
any of these crazy tactics or start
doing them
is where are you on the spectrum so an
explorer
is discovery centric so searching for
new land new ideas new things
they tend to be first movers in markets
or very early movers
and they tend to focus on the problem to
solve like the right problem to solve
for the customer
pirates on the other hand are very
market-centric they think about
all the different competitors all the
different solutions out there sometimes
you'll see
you know a grid of the features between
all these customers or all these
all these businesses and things like
that that's a very market-centric
approach
they tend to be fast followers so if you
have if you're running a pirate ship you
typically
have a ton of like engineers for example
that can build something really fast
faster than anybody else
and then they generally build solutions
and that's what i mean by faster than
anyone else
their world view tends to be more skewed
on
we can build it faster we can build it
better um
and their definition of better is just
like more of a feature list or a
checklist
and you know in my experience people
fall
pretty pretty much one way or another on
the spectrum but the reason i'm saying
this and
and i brought it up in relation to
competition and even like context
so you have to understand yourself and
and understand where you are on the
spectrum and whether
you need to move in a certain direction
or not me personally i tend to be more
of an explorer
uh there's things i appreciate about
pirates uh and
and i've been trying to sort of figure
out how to think more uh like a pirate
sometimes so i have built that
sort of checklist and stuff like that
just to explore kind of how i can
think and how i can be
this is one of the quotes if you've ever
emailed me it's a quote at the bottom
of my email i'm not going to change it
it's really the words i live by
i really do believe personally
especially based on my personality type
that
i will get everything i want in life if
i help enough other people get what they
want
so with that how can i help you
come on down you got some time for
questions maybe three or four
cool okay you're the boss go ahead
actually that i thought that was great
and in a couple of minutes they're going
to be
mobbed by people so i just wanted to
introduce myself and say hi
how's it going all right nice to meet
you how you doing
i hope i speak to you soon sounds good
that was great all right
anybody got a question i like him but
still anybody got a question
that was bold nice okay my email's right
there dude and i answer email
um i actually have a question all right
so
i liked that pirates and explorers and
do you feel like
when you're getting a group together you
should have some of both on the ship
or that the ship should be the culture
of a pirate or the ship should be the
culture of an explorer
i really believe that companies are a
reflection of the founder or the
founders depending on that
and you need to understand what you are
so my advice
on that would be if you know that the
founders one is one and one is the other
or skews one way or another it's
probably uh easier to have a ship full
of both types of people
but generally in most cases from what
i've seen the company is one way or
another
and it takes a lot to change the culture
of a company it has everything to do
with the culture
hi symmetric genie of catalyst and my
question is
how much do you think of personality
should you cater to your strengths or be
uh you know working on those weaknesses
when it comes to
uh hustling versus you know trying to be
true to yourself or whatever
i i think you need to understand
yourself and and if you start looking at
a lot of the personality things um
you start thinking a lot about nature
versus nurture and i think uh
it's probably much harder to change sort
of something that's nature
especially if you have an understanding
of that so i i'd more i'd more
do to be self-helpy
i'd probably do a self-assessment first
and then figure out areas where you
actually truly believe
you should and can change there's a lot
of things about yourself that you can't
change
for me it's more it's not about changing
necessarily it's more about
understanding other people and
understanding how you can get along with
them
for example that that person i describe
our relationship with
they're no longer with my company and it
just wasn't going to work out
and i was managing them that's why i'm
sure if someone else was managing them
at our company
it would have been different but it's
just better to understand that faster
that's
that's the value of it okay thanks
hey i'm corey big fan you pop up in
everything that i see there's so many
people that are quoting you
and getting interviewed why not so it's
cool i hadn't heard that you do the
three times audible thing but i'm
curious are you are you taking notes
while you're listening to this or are
you like doing a different activity
because i listen to podcasts a lot but
afterwards i always have to go back and
like really listen to them and take
notes because just listening to it it
doesn't get internalized
yeah um the part i didn't include in
there is
i think it heavily is heavily dependent
on how you learn
and so for me i'm a audio person
so audio so actually it's even more
interesting for me i think there's a
type of person i don't know what it's
called but
if if i have audio and then i'm
ambiently around
like in a space like uh walking around i
walk around a lot when i talk
i remember the conversation much better
so for me if i can
link those two together i remember if i
just see something visually it's
actually harder for me
it's more of the spatial and the audio
and i would just study up on like how
people learn
and see how you actually learn that's
why i mentioned the other things like
reading and stuff because
some people need to see the words and
that's how they digest it some people
need to take notes in my case
i typically don't take as many notes
when it's that fast
i might listen to it multiple times but
usually i'm listening to it multiple
times because i think it's really good
and i need it over and over again to
understand the concepts but the taking
the notes part i never go back to them
yeah that's just you that wouldn't work
well for everybody yeah exactly
yeah just learn how you learn cool
thanks
yes
i think uh two questions one is uh since
you said you don't really have a true
coding background
um when you selected your first engineer
to work with you like how did you
determine that they had the qualities
and skills
to for your idea to execute it yeah
great question
um these i think these days it's a lot
different than before uh
for for me uh the engineer that's been
with us the longest uh he's actually a
partner at
crazy ag i found because i hustled
and back in 06 ish when when when the
people that originally built crazy egg
had
couldn't do anymore uh they were just
running to problems that i could
google and fix uh if i knew how to code
um
but uh i went through the ruby on
rails.org because that's when ruby on
rails was kind of
popular and i emailed literally everyone
on the list
uh that was an engineer and i spoke to i
would say
20 to 30 percent of them i've made a lot
of friends that way like uh
the folks that started gowalla back in
the day scott raymond i i bothered him
at the time
and i literally just tried to find
someone who i thought was competent